他就看是长线还是短线了，
从长线来看的话，
他也会付出相应的代价，
因为孩子不在他身边，
其实孩子跟他也不亲，
他这一辈子所有的时间尊严用来换了钱，
钱给到了孩子，
但孩子跟他不亲，
某种程度上也是够惨的。
我们俩都30岁，
自由恋爱，
结婚4年，
异地，
俩人老家是在一起的，
有一个3岁的男孩，
26年9月份上幼儿园。
我是异地的，
体制内年薪20万，
投资收入是每个月固定有6000块钱，
但不知道投资收入能持续多久。
他是大厂的员工，
经常陪客户应酬，
年薪40，
每年大概有5%~10%的上涨速度。
目前是我婆婆过来帮我带孩子。
现在的问题是元旦我去找她，
发现她得了尖锐湿疣，
在我的逼问下，
他承认是陪客户进口，
点了人摸了下面，
回家以后自己把飞机染上了。
在此之前，
我对他是非常信任的，
感情很好，
那每个月工资全部上交，
花钱是使用亲密部，
我的工资和投资收入用于家庭开支，
他的工资全部都存起来了，
他的手机我也是可以随便看的。
至于他的说辞。
我是比较偏相信的，
但这不重要。
这几天我一直都在想，
我应该怎么做，
再蓄力，
我应该怎么爆发。
我让他写了一个承诺书和感染过程。
承诺书他只写一些道歉的话，
我保证不会有第二次，
然后说不敢面对我，
害怕失去我，
但我感觉这写的很鸡累。
感染过程他不愿意写，
觉得写不下去，
我还在逼他写，
他说他不想离婚，
不想离婚就这态度，
凭什么他受的痛苦不及我万分之一，
我不想这么轻易的饶了他伤害我的人，
我一定要让他付出代价。
除了这件事以外，
他很听话，
钱全部上交，
平时对我也很关心，
对我很好，
我也是热烈深腾的付出了感情，
我给他情绪价值给的是满满的。
我一个多月去找他一次，
生活很和谐，
本来是计划几年后他回来工作，
我们住在一起，
我该怎么解决这个问题，
才能保证我和孩子的利益最大化？
我纠结要不要离婚，
是因为我舍不得这包我现在手上的钱我觉得太少了，
目前我没有一辆车，
存款50万全在我这儿，
离婚的话他可以净身出户，
但我感觉钱太少了，
我和我儿子要很多钱，
因为这几年房价动荡，
一直没买房，
本来就是二七年以后我们打算买房的，
他家有一个小厂子，
目前他爸妈手上大概有1。
在50万左右的现金，
最近厂子还不错，
年入大概有大几十，
我抚养孩子需要学区房，
我娘家没有住意的，
但我又咽不下这口气，
我想要报复她，
她是独死了，
她还有一个姐姐，
跟公公婆婆相处怎么样啊，
坚持的挺好的，
你跟他相隔多长时间的车程啊？
我们坐飞机的话，
大概要两个多小时，
两个半到三个小时，
经常是你去看她，
她很少回来看你是吧？
对的，
他一般就是很难请假的，
你现在主要的诉求是想报复他，
不是我现在主要的诉求是我咽不下这口气，
我怎样才能让自己的利益最大化，
同时出了这口气，
我觉得啊，
你先把他所有的病例，
确实是这个平时是有的，
生病的这些记录你先保存好，
都存好了，
现在也算是拿着把柄了，
拿着把柄了，
那以后就公司上交呗，
你就给他零花钱呗，
就一直上交的，
就多攒钱呗，
钱到了你手上，
其实将来你有两种方案，
一种方案的话，
买房子登记在孩子名下，
因为孩子一直是你带，
孩子跟他的可能性是比较小的，
大概率下孩子是要跟你的，
因为他没法带孩子，
如果说买房子直接买在孩子名下，
孩子又是你带，
又跟你生活在一起的话，
这不约等于这房子也就归你了吗？
但是有一个问题是，
买房子买在我的名下，
我不。
去堵他家里人和他愿不愿意你在孩子名下，
这样的话，
孩子上学区房啊干干嘛的，
这也会影响，
是不是这样对你来说更有利一点，
因为我是这么考虑这个问题的啊，
我听你的诉求呢，
钱还不够多，
还想让对方多挣钱，
为你和孩子做贡献，
那在这个阶段的话，
是不太适合去签什么协议，
说啊车子归你，
说什么存款归你，
不太适合，
就有点打草惊蛇了，
那个意思，
但是你把他的尖锐是疣得病的经过，
聊天的记录，
这些他自己描述的这些事儿，
你都作为证据先保留着，
保留了，
那我觉得问题也不大呀，
他反正每年能挣四五十万呢，
是吧，
他家庭条件也这么好啊，
等到你们真要买房子的时候，
假设要买在孩子名下的时候，
是不是公公婆婆也会出力啊，
因为买在你的名下容易产生债务纠纷，
真到离的时候的话，
可能发生一些公公婆婆觉得这是借款要起诉你，
让你还钱的问题，
那如果买在孩子名下的话，
很难发生债务纠纷了，
就对我当时也是这么想的，
就可能买个房子买在我儿子的名下，
因为他现在未成年了，
是不是要去做一个公证什么的，
如果是全款买的话，
比如说公公婆婆借点钱，
是不是全款支持一点，
全款买的话，
未成年人也可以直接买房子的的，
你自己也要去做预防针，
副架啊，
打酒驾啊，
自己也要做全面的这样。
一个排查，
因为他有可能有潜伏期啊，
有什么的，
隔个三个月5个月的时候自己再去做一次检查，
如果说HPV没有感染的话，
那就证明你身体抵抗力挺好的，
没啥大事儿，
但是他那头一定是要配合治疗嘛，
对不对？
嗯，
确定他那头不具有传染性嘛，
在有夫妻的生活嘛，
但是他们这些东子出来了以后，
我觉得一定要让他付出代价的，
他的代价是你现在已经清醒的知道了要用他，
而不再是一个恋爱脑，
不再是一个爱的那么热烈的投入的这样一个人，
这就是他付出的代价呀，
我这边肯定是清醒了，
但是我要让他知道他伤害我的这件事情，
一定要是他自己，
我也要让他痛苦，
那就算是长线还是短线了，
从长线来看的话，
他也会付出相应的代价，
因为孩子不在他身边，
其实孩子跟他也不亲，
他这一辈子所有的时间尊严用来换了钱，
钱给到了孩子，
但孩子跟他不亲，
某种程度上也是够惨的，
我们每天呢，
他会给我发消息，
我很冷淡的回复嘛，
我也会回的，
但是会隔一段时间再回，
而且会回的比较冷淡，
我今天还跟他讲，
我让他再把感染的过程再写给我，
我就逼他们让他再写给我，
然后我们要写呀，
录音也可以啊，
就我跟。
讲，
我今天晚上跟他说，
今天晚上我们再聊一下吧，
真诚的聊一下，
这样也可以啊，
录音也可以作为证据啊，
好吧，
嗯，
那我后面还要怎么做，
我要不要把这件事情跟他的家里面人讲，
不要，
如果你还要长期的用人家就不要讲，
我前前几天真的是有点轻松了，
但是我一直把自己给按下去了，
就一直没有跟任何人讲不要讲啊，
好，
那就这样啊，
等会的，
谢谢了，
好拜拜，
男方感染了尖锐是疣，
他给的解释也是挺新鲜挺那啥的，
挺新奇的，
男方给的那个解释是吧，
说陪着领导去KTV摸了一下，
摸了一下回去他自己再解决一下自己的问题，
好，
他赶了上监狱室疣了，
就他那个解释，
到时候你们去评论区看啊，
五花八门的啊，
我今天一整天我的功德白攒了，
笑没了被我记得点赞关注哦。